a self-confessed Chinese spy in
Australia says that he's offered a trove
of intelligence information Wang Li
Chang says that he's turned against
Beijing and revealed the identities of
senior Chinese military intelligence
officers in Hong Kong
he's also provided details on how
Beijing's operatives fund and conduct
interference operations in Hong Kong
Taiwan and Australia Wang is now seeking
asylum and says he could face the death
penalty if he returns to China
Australia's government does not get
indicated whether it will grant him
asylum well these are very disturbing
reports the matter is now in the hands
of the appropriate law enforcement
agencies and so I wouldn't comment on
the particulars of individual cases but
what I would say is that the government
makes no apologies for the strong
measures that we have taken to ensure
that we have foreign interference laws
in place that we are resourcing how law
enforcement intelligence agencies like
never before and that we will always
stand up for our national interest
whether it's on matters of foreign
policy foreign investment or other
related issues Nick McKenzie is an
investigative journalist at the age and
the Sydney Morning Herald he was he
spoken to what Wang he joins us now live
from Melbourne good to have you with us
Nick who is this guy how valuable was
the information that he's provided I
think it's fair to say it's extremely
valuable the world for some time
intelligence agencies experts analysts
have written a lot about how they
suspect Chinese intelligence operates
Chinese interference operates in places
like Australia Hong Kong Taiwan and
elsewhere but to have an insider's
account somebody who says this is what I
did this is what I saw this is what I
heard and this is how the system
operates and this is how we undermined
the independence movement in Hong Kong
this is how the election meddled in
Taiwan is of course extremely valuable
this is all the Cold War stuff isn't it
how is China able to recruit ethnic
Chinese to to spy for it in these these
places well we know that the Chinese
government has one of the biggest
intelligence
verses in the world in this case this
intelligence operative was working in
according to his account a Hong Kong
front company a listed Hong Kong company
it has links to the Chinese military
some of those links are quite reasonably
publicly found using that cover as a
Hong Kong businessman he conducted
various operations and perhaps one of
the more notable operations involved in
the kidnapping of one of the Causeway
Bay book shop sellers this is where five
book sellers were disappeared rendered
to the mainland one claims he had
personal involvement in the kidnapping
of one of these people he conveyed
information to the kidnap team just
simply one of them fairly stunning
revelations he's made to us in to
Australian authorities how many more
like him are there especially in
Australia itself
well Australia is a tip of the spear in
some respects in the Western world in
respect to this issue of Chinese
government foreign interference and the
assessments that I've been given by
Australian government authority to know
about these issues is that he's not
unusual there are many people like him
following the orders of the Chinese
government in Australia and elsewhere
engaged in serious acts of foreign
interference that's not to say of course
the vast majority of Chinese Australian
director absolutely wonderful the
law-abiding citizens there is of course
though a significant if it being taken
by the Chinese Communist Party if I must
make a distinction between it and of
course the Chinese population the
Chinese Communist Party in Australia is
engaged in serious acts of foreign
interference our government has recently
passed new security laws aimed at
curbing those acts it's fair to say our
security agencies are slowly beginning
to try to enforce those laws at the
moment one our insiders says the Chinese
government is acting really with
impunity in Australia and elsewhere the
fact that there's not been one single
prosecution of a Chinese spy in
Australia suggests he may be right as we
said
Australia's government hasn't yet
indicated whether it will
him asylum should he be given asylum
well in its early days yet obviously and
his story has been public only a matter
of hours very senior Australian MP the
chair of the Australian Parliament's
Committee on security and intelligence
Andrew hasty MP has come forward and
said he should be granted asylum and
protection urgently I suspect he'll be
joined by other senior politicians in
Australia every indication we have is
that the Australian Government believes
this man's story to be credible the
intelligence he's sharing to be useful
it's no doubt going to be shared amongst
the five eyes intelligence network and
of course what he's done is put major
target on himself for the rest of his
life he can't go back to Hong Kong he
certainly can't go back to these to the
mainland where he was born the Chinese
mainland so really one would expect him
to getting a protection visa and perhaps
residency sometime in the near future
why did he go public Nick he says he
went public because having conducted
five years of covert espionage
operations he was given a mission to
travel to Taiwan on a false South Korean
passport we've seen that passport we've
seen under false papers he was given to
enter Taiwan the orders he was given
were to alekhya to meddle in the
Taiwanese 2020 presidential election
he'd already committed a significant act
according to himself of election
meddling in the previous regional
elections in Taiwan but this next
assignment for him was the line in the
sand he has a wife studying in Australia
as a young child in Australia he
travelled to Australia in April this
year and made a decision he would return
to Hong Kong and did not want to undergo
the next mission he'd been given and so
has been hiding out in Sydney ever since
I guess more broadly he according to him
has had a crisis of conscience he is
tired of serving a regime he no longer
believes in he's seen that China's
Communist Party engaged in acts that he
believes improper and he no longer wants
to help them fulfill their course so
he's come to Australia
he says his embracing democracy and he's
he's wishing and seeking energy
protection good to talk to you Nick many
thanks indeed Nick McKenzie there from
the Aged and Sydney Morning Herald thank
you